على بعدي ايام قليله من انطلاق كاس العالم
في قطر تحولت بعض الاحياء والمناطق الى
وجهات رئيسيه تستمل الزوار والمشجعين
الباحثين عن اجواء وطقوس المونديال من بين
هذه المناطق سمكه سوق واقف الذي يعتبر
مدخلا رئيسا للاقتراب من الحضاره القطريه
ومؤخرا ايضا فضاء لمناقشه اخر المستجدات
الرياضيه
في محل للتذكرات وفي المقاهي المجاوره
تختلف الاجناس واللكنات لكن الانظار تتجه
الى نفس المكان
مونديال قطر ذلك الموعد الذي تحول الى
عنوان رئيسي في كل نقاشات احنا
بزاف المنتخب ديالنا خصوصا مني
جانا حمد الله وكما كتعرف الدور دياله مهم
خصوصا عندنا نقص في الهجوم وهذه هو
المشكله اللي ربما كانواجهوها حاليا من
اصاله سوق واقف الى حداثه درب الحسين
يتغير العمران ولا يتغير الشغف باجواء
المونديال في هذه المنطقه التي ستحظى بشرف
بتنظيم المباراه النهائيه
لكن قبل تلك اللحظه يعلم هؤلاء ان كره
القدم لم تكن قط حديثه الملاعب لذلك ارتدى
بعضهم قميصه الوطني وردد اناشيد سيتسع
صداها بعد خادم الايام
[موسيقى]
طبعا كمان شاهد الحين في درب الوسيل في
البوليفارد جميع الوفود والجماهير قبل ما
توفيت على دوله قطر وكاس العالم خلاص ما
بقى له كم يوم همم ونرحب بالجميع في لوحه
الجميع وان شاء الله نكون همم يعني نحسن
ضيافهم في دوله من الحبيبه قطر
ويسالون اسئله كثيره عن البلد ثقافتها من
جهتها رنه تنظيمه هذا المونديال في مكان
قطر سيطفي عليه طبعا خاصه سيجعله حدثا
عالميا غير مسبوق
ذلك استشراف ستتكشف معالمه قريبا في بلد
سيصبح محطه انظار العالم عند انطلاق صفاره
البدايه في ملعب البيت بيت العلم ايمن
زبير الجزيره الدوحه